hello um so um hello everybody
today i will talk to you about micrornas
in extracellular vesicles and how they
orchestrate
the biology of the tumor
microenvironment
first of all i would like to make my
disclosure so i
have no financial relationships to
disclose
the outline of today's talk will be
essentially in these four points the
first part of the lecture
will be on the classification of
extracellular vesicles
and we will talk about the physiology of
micrornas
since the topic of this talk is the role
of micrornas in extracellular vesicles
and how they shape the biology of the
tumor microenvironment
then we will talk about the classical or
traditional
mechanisms of action of micrornas and
their alternative or more
novel discoveries about how they work
and then
we will talk about the discovery of mere
sectors and i will define what i mean by
that
and what is their implication in the
biology of the tumor micro environment
and then we will focus a little bit more
on a specific
aspect of the biology of vesicular
micrornas with reference to
the natural killer derived exosomal
micrornas and how they shape the biology
of the tme
so um the classification of
extracellular vesicles
is listed here it's not complete and
it's constantly changing so
but it reflects essentially what we know
as of yet regarding how we can classify
extracellular vesicles
a lot of people think that the term
exosome
is a synonym for extracellular testicles
well this is incorrect because exosomes
are just
the one subtype of ev or extracellular
vesicles
which includes a broader family of
vesicles and to be more specific
exosomes can be considered as this
some of the smallest type of vesicles
indeed as you see
in the in this slide under the size
column you see that exosomes have
a range in size between 40 and
nanometers whereas the micro vesicles
have a range between 50 nanometers and
one micron
and then we have apoptotic bodies that
the range between 500 nanometers and 2
microns
but there are also other uh categories
of eds that have been
more recently identified one
includes smaller vesicles than exosomes
that are the ectosomes that are
between 10 and 20 nanometers and then we
have
large oncosomes that are actually
vesicles that are bigger than the other
than the apoptotic bodies
and whose size range is between 1 micron
and 10 microns
now as you can see from this slide
though that a pure
size is not good enough to differentiate
the different type of vesicles
because there are areas of overlapping
if you just look at the size of them
let's say for instance you have the
vesicles that is 100 nanometers you
wouldn't be able just
based on the size to determine or to
state
that that vesicle is an exosome or a
micro vesicle
so how can you differentiate between
these two different groups of vesicles
there are different criterias
um some of them include essentially
looking at surface marker expression
in particular exosomes tend to express
tetraspanning such as t-span 29 t-span
30 um other mem other
molecules such as dsg-101 and so on
micro vesicles tend to express integrins
cd40 ligand
and selectings apoptotic bodies are
characterized by the
extensive amount of phosphatidylserine
because of the flapping of the
um lipids in the membrane when
the the cell dies um
originally it was quite difficult to
differentiate different type of evs so
at some point
the international society for
extracellular vesicles
isaf came up with um
a series of guidelines that are called
the minimal requirement
for the definition of an extracellular
vesicles as an
exosome or as another type of evs among
the different listed before and i have
to say that this is a very helpful uh
tool because
it allows all scientists from different
labs to essentially start talking the
same language
and start defining their vesicles with
the proper name
based on the criteria that need to be
met in order to
define a vesicle in a certain way or
another these
guidelines are constantly updated there
has been an update
in november of 2017 from the original
publication
in december 2014 and we are we have
constantly
so so you are encouraged to follow the
updates that the society
provides in terms of the requirement for
the definition of the different
subcategories of evs
um just to keep going about the
physiology of these extracellular
vesicles
uh the exosomes so that the category
that ranges between 30 40 to 120
nanometers in size and expresses
tetraspanins
are derived from the endosomal
compartment so as you can see here
they are originating through different
mechanisms
involving escort dependent and escort
independent machinery from the mvb
here at the center of the slide which
stays for multivesicular body
and then these mvbs under undergo a
maturation inside of the cytosol of the
cell
and can essentially follow two paths one
is to go through degradation inside of
lysosomes
the other one is to migrate through the
plasma membrane mainly
thanks to arab 27 members
that allows the migration of the late
mvv
through the plasma membrane where the
membrane of the mvp
fuses with the plasma membrane releasing
the little tiny exosomes outside of the
cell
um differently than that
you have that micro vesicles as you can
see
in the upper left part of this cartoon
seem to originate
mostly from a direct blabbing
of the plasma membrane so with the
minimum involvement
of the endosomal compartment and
machinery
this is uh at this point almost a
historic
image it was one of the first images of
extracellular vesicles bleeding from the
surface
of glioblastoma cells
in the seminal paper of
dr skug with uh um coming from the group
of sandra bradfield at harvard
they were able to show indeed for the
first time that there is
um the these vesicles blabbing from the
surface of cells can actually
be imaged and extracellular vesicles
really contain
a whole different types of cargo
molecules
essentially it has been shown that every
possible
macromolecule you can think of can uh
be part of the cargo of evs so inside of
evs you can find
proteins of course you can find also me
i'm not sure what happened here
so okay so you can find ev you can find
proteins you can
find messenger rnas you can find
um non-coding rnas both micrornas and
long non-coding rnas and people have
described also
dna inside of vesicles and also
as i said previously vesicles are
characterized by the different type of
molecules that define their surface
landscape briefly i would like to go
through
some seminal discoveries on the
role of extracellular vesicles in cancer
this is from the group of david lydon
and they were the first
to provide evidence that
melanoma-derived exosomes
are able to educate bone marrow
progenitors by
transferring um the oncogenic
oncogene mat and also they were able to
show that exosomes are able to induce a
vascular leakiness at the premetastatic
niche
and so if you block it up 27
a which is one of the proteins involved
in the migration of the multivesicular
body to the plasma membrane
this decreases the exosome formation and
metastases
and they were able to identify also
specific exosomic
melanoma signature which involves genes
such as terp2
vla4 hsp70 and matte
with prognostic implications so it was
the first paper really showing
convincingly that the protein and
oncogene can be transferred
from cancer-derived exosomes to cells
of the pre-metastatic niche priming it
to receive metastatic cells
and then another uh seminal paper here
from
michiel pectel and jacofan nerinen
they were able to show that for the
first time
in vivo that there is an effect
of exosomes on
other cells of the tumor
microenvironment so vesicles released
from the cancer cells can actually
have an effect that can be actually
documented in vivo
on other cells of the tumor micro
environment using a very elegant system
that combines equilox
evidence of an effect of
the content the cargo of vesicles on the
recipient cells in the tme in vivo
then a ragu kaluri's group provided the
first
evidence that surface um
markers of vesicles such as gleepikan1
can be used to identify
cancer-derived exosomes particularly
beneficial in the early diagnosis of
pancreatic cancer
so providing a lot of hope of course for
patients that have this type of cancer
because
as you know and as we speak this is
still a very deadly type of cancer and
the early diagnosis represents probably
the most powerful tool we have
as of yet for the um healing and the
treatment of this disease so having
an early marker to be detected in in
circulating exosome is certainly a very
powerful tool
against this disease another important
paper again from the
group of david lydon provided the first
evidence that actually vesicles are
involved
in the tropism of metastatic cells
so in other words um cancer cells seems
to be directed
to a specific target metastatic
organ um after this organ has been
primed by the vesicles by the exosome
released by these cancer cells so they
did
a series of very elegant experiments
showing that
if you have let's say um cancer a breast
cancer cell line that has
tropism for the lung and one breast
cancer cell line that has a tropism for
the brain for instance
if you prime the animal with the
exosomes derived from the cell that has
tropism from the lung and then you put
the cells that tends to go to the brain
these cells actually will go to the lung
just because there has been a priming
from the exosomes derived from
a long tropic uh cell line so this was a
very powerful
evidence that the vesicles have an
incredible uh
central role play an incredible center
central role in the definition
of the target organ for the metastatic
process
they were able also to identify which
genes are
involved in these traffic of the
vesicles
showing in particular that specific type
of integrins
expressed in the surface of the vesicles
tend to define
a certain tropic tropism certain organ
as the destination of the vesicle itself
and then the group of dolores divizio
and colleagues at cedar sinai
uh have provided a very broad and
extensive definition
of the role of large oncosomes so that
the biggest
group of vesicles we can think of as of
yet
so the ones that range from let's say 1
micron to 10 microns they were able to
show that
specifically highly metastatic prostate
cancer cells
tend to release this large onco zone
and this contributes significantly to
the metastatic process
so this was a little bit of a background
on that some of the most relevant
literature in the field
and now i want to go a little bit more
specifically on the topic of this talk
defining the after i define the vesicles
defining the other
main character in this plot in the story
that i'm about to share with you
so micro rnas i'm not sure
all of you are familiar with micrornas
that's why i provided these
apparently complicated slide but
actually it's not that complicated
if you follow me step by step that tells
you about the biogenesis and especially
the physiology and the function of micro
rnas
so starting from the um
[Music]
elliptical blue area in the upper left
side of these
uh supposed to be gigantic cell
that represents the nucleus of the cell
so just to tell you that microorganisms
like every other
protein coding gene is actually is
a gene so is a piece of dna which is
transcribed
uh through to into a pre-micrornas so
primordial pri
microrna you have to pay attention to
letters here to
pri and so this primordial microrna
is then processed inside of the nucleus
of the cell
by an enzyme called drosha with the
coenzyme called the dg cr8
into a precursor micro rna so pre
microrna which is
characterized by a hairpin structure is
a helping precursor
and this pre-microrna is then
shifted from the nucleus inside of the
inside of the cytoplasm of the cell
by means of exporting five with a
coenzyme called rand gtp
and here the premicron am needs a
ribonuclear
nucleoprotein complex called risk which
is composed of different parts
the first one is dicer which essentially
takes away the loop of the mirror
leaving a duplex which is opened by a
helicase
and then for thermodynamic uh reasons
one of the two strands
of the duplex is preferred and becomes
the mature single stranded microrna
which is long about
19 to 24 nucleotides and
guided by other proteins in the risk
complex mainly
argonaut 2 in humans finds an
a complementary or almost complementary
sequence
in a target messenger rna mostly but not
exclusively as we will see in a minute
um at the three prime utr end of the
transcript
as a consequence you can have mostly a
translational repression
if there is an imperfect base pair
pairing of the microrna with the target
messenger rna
sometimes and especially in plants more
than in humans
you have a perfect match between all the
bases of the microrna
and the target messenger rna in which
case you have
an actual cleavage of both the messenger
rna
and the rna in 2007
a brilliant discovery by vasudevan and
colleague showed for the first time
that actually um microrna can also
bind to the five prime utr of
a gene and as a consequence of that you
can have actually an increase the
translation so not a decrease
translation will actually increase the
expression of the proteins
here is a summary of the possible
outcome of the microarray
messenger rna interaction most
frequently you have what's happening in
the top
part of the cartoon so you have the
microrna attached to the
risk complex binding to the three prime
utr of the target messenger rna
and you can have a messenger rna
degradation especially if the
match is perfect or you can have
translational repression if the match is
imperfect or doesn't occur in all
of the 100 percent of all the bases of
the micro name matching to the three
prime utr
uh if you have a binding to the five
prime utr region you can have still a
translational repression
but you can have also the translational
activation i was mentioning before
microrna can also bind to the coding
sequence and these
almost invariably results
into a translational repression and
that's pretty much all the outcome you
can have
having said that in
more recent years um different groups
have shown that
in addition to these traditional
mechanisms of action of microrna which
is which are the ones we just analyzed
you can have also alternative mechanisms
of action which are listed here
in the left you see again one of the
first
alternative mechanism as i said is the
fact that the mirrors can actually
increase the translation of a messenger
rna into a protein
and then on the right side you have a
brilliant observation done by
dr erin at the time she was working in
dr danilo peratti's lab
they were the first to show that a
microrna can actually interact
directly with a protein so not with the
messenger rna
in this specific work they were showing
that mere 328
by binding to a protein called hrnp
e2 were able to subtract or take away
this
hrnp e2 factor from its binding to a
transcription factor called cebp
alpha and normally hrnp e2 inhibits
cebp alpha but the presence of the mir
prevents this inhibition and so cbp
alpha allows the transcription
of factors that allow a granulocytic
differentiation
now in leukemias you have a dow
regulation of mere 328
therefore hrnpe2 is free to bind and
inhibit cvp alpha so there is a block
internal acidic differentiation which is
key to the um
leukemic process the hemogenic process
but the point here that i'm trying to
highlight is the fact that this paper is
the first one
showing a completely different mechanism
of action for micrornas
as um able to interact with
a protein instead of a messenger rna
so this is very important this
observation that micrornas can bind to
protein is very important for the story
i'm about to share
the other background to the story is
this
table which is just a very um
oversimplification of the of the
situation but it gives you
an idea where we are going from here
so at some point in the microrna history
uh people started looking at the
expression of micrornas in the blood
first and then essentially they started
looking all possible biological fluids
and the first uh paper
that actually looked at micrornas from
this perspective is actually the second
one listed here
so to give the right credit to the right
people so
by mitchell at all they showed that in
prostate cancer patients you have high
level
of circulating in the blood mere 141
compared to healthy men the the other
counterpart
so why is this a paper important and the
other ones listed here because these
were the first
um papers showing for the first time
that micrornas can be
can be effectively used as cancer
biomarkers because they can be
found in a biological fluids and they
can actually
predict if a patient has cancer or not
and in those years actually in 2007
valadi at all of the group of young
lotte
provided a very at the very first
evidence
that micrornas can be shuttled
functionally from one cell to another
inside of extracellular vesicles
and when i mean what i mean by
functionally i mean that
um cell number one here you see mast
cell number one
releases micrornas inside of
extracellular vesicles
and if you take the supernatant not the
cell but just the supernatant
from this cell culture must sell number
one and you put it on the top
of mast cell number two which is in a
completely different flask and so has
never been
in any contact with mast cell number one
except for the fact that you put the
supernatant derived from number one
into number two you have the these
microrna contained in the vesicles
released by mast cell number one
enter into mast cell number two
and they start targeting messenger rnas
in this
recipient cell it was a very fundamental
observation
that essentially was telling us that
microrna can shuttle from one cell to
another
inside of it so now putting these
three pieces of evidence i just provided
in the previous three slides
together so the fact that micrornas can
bind to proteins
the fact that they can be found
circulating and the fact that they can
be transferred from one cell to another
prompted me and my group to
think of micrornas in a completely
different
setting not only as
regulators of gene expression by
modulating the translation
rate of messenger rna but actually as
hormones because if you think of
hormones the definition of a hormone is
a molecule
which is secreted by one cell which is
part of a gland
goes into circulation and does something
on an
effector cell so at the distance by
binding
mostly through uh to a protein receptor
so it seems like that the picture here
fits quite
nicely the definition of the hormone of
course
this was a very high risk idea because
hormones are considered to be mainly
belong to two categories being proteins
or
lipids nobody has ever thought of um
hormones as being nucleic acids but
we decided to move on with this
hypothesis because it seemed quite
um possible based on the premises
so uh in 2012 uh we published a paper
uh in which we started by uh screening
which micrornas were included as a cargo
of
extracellular vesicles released released
by
non-small cell lung cancer cell lines
and as you see in the
tunnel a you here we have several dots
each of them representing a microgrenade
detected
with the nanostring technology escargo
of microrna derived from
these cancer cell lines and then the red
dot that you see
actually represents the statistical
threshold so that whatever is underneath
is considered
noise so it's not necessarily really
there
but so basically this killed a lot of
our candidates but
we still had nine candidates that were
expressed above the threshold
and then we decided to validate these
list of nine candidates
with an another technique which was the
quantitative real-time pcr
which you see listed in v here
and we ended up showing that indeed um
they were like in particular mir 21 and
mere 29a
which were highly expressed in the lung
cancer cell line
compared to a cell line which was used
as a control 293 cells that as you know
are not um lung cells and are not even
cancer cells so we had at this point two
candidates mere 21 and 29
a that were very highly uh represented
as cargo of
vesicles released by non-small cell lung
cancer cell lines
but then the problem was okay so if
these hormones
if this microwave work as hormones first
off how do they work
and what is the destination cell so we
decided to
look at different proteins that are
known
to bind to single stranded rna which are
about 19 to 24 nucleotides in size
and actually they were two excellent
candidates and they belong to the family
of toll-like receptor family a family in
particular two like receptors seven
and eight that are known to bind the two
single stranded rna
of viral origin so exogenous to the cell
that's their main
function to defend cells from infections
from exogenous rnas
but we thought they interact they could
be also
mere receptors so receptors of microrna
and transfer for instance from a cancer
cell
to a recipient cell so we started a
series of experiments
of colocalization that are listed here
so first off
we um focused on the top three
the top two candidates we we obtained
from the previous screening so mere 21
and 29a
we use the mere 16 because it was
expressed
equally in lung cancer cells and in
293 cells and so we use the lyso tracker
to label
the endosomal compartment where the two
like receptors seven and eight are
located inside the cytoplasma cells
we labeled the tone like receptor aid
itself
with green gfp and we created artificial
exosomes containing the micrornas of
interest labeled in
red and when we did the merging images
when you see
yellow it means colocalization so we
observe that all three
micrornas are able to enter the
recipient cell
from the artificial exosomes and
localize
in the endosomal compartment where the
toe like is located
of course this doesn't mean that the
mirror interacts with the receptor for
that
we had to perform immunoprecipitations
that you see
in the bar in the upper right side so
here we precipitated the um
protein so the two like receptor and we
observed an enrichment for mere 21 and
29
a but not so much for a mere 16
whereas below you see that we pull down
the microrna
and you obtain like receptor eight only
with mere
29a and mere 21 but not with mere 16
or total which is the empty vesicle that
we use the plus of the other controls
and then the images you see underneath
they show that the main producer of
these
uh this is this micrornas in this case
is mere 29a
represented here is actually the cancer
cell not
the normal lung tissue counterpart
so we so we perform a series of the
colloquialization experiments uh
inside hybridization and at the end of
the day we were able to show that the
recipient cell
is the um tumor-associated macrophage
especially at the so-called
tumor interface so at the line
of demarcation between the cancerous
tissue
and the normal tissue in the normal
tissue surrounding it
and so we were able to formulate this
model in which we see that the cancer
cell the non-small cell and cancer cell
is able to secrete
vesicles containing mere 21 and year 29a
that is updating if taken taken by
tumor-associated macrophages especially
the interface with the tumor
and here the exosome or vesicles i
should say a fuses with the endosomal
compartment where the toe like receptor
ate in human
or its counter part in mouse which is
the lr7
is able to bind literally physically
with the
microrna triggering the downstream
signaling of
the receptor which is an f cap beta
signaling
which induces the secretion of tnf and
interleukin-6
which promote promotes tumor growth and
the metastatic potential
in a later publication in 2015
um dr chala gundla who now at the time
was a postdoc in my lab now is an
assistant professor at the university of
nebraska so he was able to show that the
same crosstalk
is important in neuroblastoma so in
pediatric
cancer and again neuroblastoma cells
like lung cancer cells previously are
able to secrete mere 21
interestingly we didn't see the
secretion of mere 29a from this cell
line
but this mir-21 then is a taken by the
tumor-associated macrophages where it
binds to
like receptor eight triggers an f kappa
beta
activation which um transactivates the
expression of mere 155 so another
microrna
normally very little expressed in the
cancer cell itself
so the up regulation of mere 155 in the
macrophage
and makes it also packed inside of the
exosomes derived from these macrophages
and transfer back to the cancer cell
where these microrna targets genes such
as turf1
which is an inhibitor of telomerase
activity which induces increased
telomeres activity and increased
resistance to cisplatin showing that
these uh
apparent crosstalk between cancer cells
and macrophages mediated by the binding
to a mere sector the other aid
is actually relevant also for the
mechanisms of drug
resistance now i'm shifting gears a
little bit and telling you about some
more recent studies that are being
performed have been performed and are
being
performed in my lab and so we focused on
another important cellular component of
innate immunity which are
the natural killer cells as you know
natural killer cells
are prime cells to destroy
virally infected cells as well as tumor
cells
however so and they responded to a
series of signals
exchanged between the um cell
and the nk cell itself in particular
some signals are a permissive so they
actually
allow the killing of the cell by the nk
cells
some other cells some other signals are
inhibitory so they
tell nk cells essentially do not kill me
and based on the combination of these
two
groups of signals you have an outcome
which is the fact that the nk
cell actually does kill or not
but to complicate things and what
happens in the tumor micro environment
is that it has been shown
quite clearly at this point that the
tumor micro environment
of several type of cancers is literally
imbued so full enriched in tgf
beta and tgf beta is a profound
inhibitor of nk killing activity
so one of the ways for um cancer cells
to
escape the killing by nk cells is indeed
we have
a micro environment which is
particularly rich of
tgf beta the idea here uh the
overarching hypothesis here of this
project is that
perhaps we can use exosomes
so particles derived from nk cells
instead of nk cell themselves to kill
cancer cells
and why would we think of that for a
series of reasons the first one
is that one of the problems that you
have every time
really you perform a cell therapy so
nk cell therapy included is that you
have
one or one important side effect of the
injection of cells
as therapeutic seeing patients is that
you might have the so-called
cytokine storm which is a situation in
which there is like an
a strong secretion of cytokines that can
actually lead to
important side effects like a very
excruciating headache or very high fever
that ultimately might lead the
oncologist even to stop the treatment
because
the side effects are just unbearable and
so at this point
the therapy is not effective anymore
because you have to stop it because of
side effects
so the idea here is that perhaps with
the vesicles instead of the cells
themselves you might actually
be able to prevent this cytokine storm
issue
from happening the other possibilities
which is number two here
is that uh you know cancer cells
especially leukemic cells
tend to have nests so to hide um
in the so-called pharmacologic
sanctuaries so
one being the brain another one being
the testis
where there is like a brain blood
barrier or a testis blood barrier
that prevents therapeutics and actually
in particular
cell therapeutics to cross the barrier
and enter
that compartment where the cancer cell
is actually nesting
so um and it has been shown actually at
this point by several papers that
vesicles derived from different type of
cells
including nk cells seems to be able to
cross
quite easily these um barriers this
anatomical barrier
that um you know cancer cells
use to to hide and so this way these
vesicles as therapeutics can actually
reach also these pharmacological
sanctuaries
then of course all the signaling that
occurs between cancer cells and nk cells
so in particular the
inhibitory signaling perhaps are not at
stake are not
necessarily involved in the killing
mediated by
vesicles if you use vesicles instead of
this nk cell as therapeutic so
based on all these uh ideas we decided
to
follow up on these um interesting
hypotheses
and first off you know to make sure that
we can even go this way we have to be
able to obtain big quantities of
exosomes derived from nk
cells and this has been possible thank
you
thanks to this paper by denman and all
that has been
optimized in collaboration with dr bob
seger and dr young at children's
hospital los angeles
we were able to develop these
modified protocol in which we start from
peripheral blood mononuclear cells
that are put in contact with engineer
the k562 cells
so that essentially after like two weeks
of co-culture you have
a population of more than 95 percent
pure nk cells from which you can isolate
the vesicles that are at this point
almost all derived from
nk cells that are activated and so then
we were able to define the properties of
these nk derived vesicles and defined
that they fulfilled a minimal
requirement
of isaac the international society to
call them exosomes so that's why we use
this term from now on
but of course the one million dollar
question is are these vesicles able
actually to kill cancer cells or not
so here you see in two different
neuroblastoma cell lines
uh that it progressing from the
left to the right you have progressively
increasing concentration of vesicles and
gateride vesicles
and these cells these cancer cells are
luciferous labels so
when they die when they are killed you
see a down regulation
in the signal because the cells are not
you know um
expressing luciferase anymore because
they're dying so you see that in both
cases at some point
we have we reach a concentration of
vesicles that are able to significantly
inhibit
the um growth of these cells
or to kill the cells i should say and
interestingly while
in chla255 so you look at the green bars
here
there seems to be a plateau that is
reached after which even if you keep
going up with the concentration of
vesicles the cells do not keep
kill being killed more and more in the
chla 136 so in the purple
bars you see that there seems to be a
progressively increased dying
with the increased concentration of
vesicles
then we performed a series of functional
experiments these were performed by dr
nediani
and now he's directing an extracellular
vesicle core facility
at children's hospital los angeles which
i encourage you to check in on the
website if you need
excellent work characterizing your
vesicles at the time it was a postdoc in
my lab
and he performed these experiments
showing that
especially not only um vesicles are able
to kill
as well as nk cells but what we observed
is that if you have an environment in
which you have
tgs data then and
nk cells are not killing anymore as we
expect
but nk derived exosomes keep
killing as if tgf beta wasn't present
and so this is a very important
observation because it tells us that
an advantage that honestly we didn't
even foresee when we were thinking of
using vesicles versus the cells
an advantage a further advantage of
using vesicles over the cells
is actually that they can work and they
can kill cancer cells even in presence
of a lot of tgf data which was that
cytokine that was
inhibiting the function of nk cells
and of course then we also performed
this experiment in which we
um silenced
the uh expression of drosha which is key
in the machinery of
micrornas and we were able to so
basically we silenced russia in nk cells
so this point we impaired the production
of
micrornas by nk cells we took the
exosome from these treated cells nk
cells and we put it on the top of chla
136 and checked for the killing
and as you can see if you silence russia
these vesicles from nk cells are not as
good as
in in killing as neurograms as if the
russia was present
so that tells us that micrornas are
among the different components of the
cargo of these nk derived cells
are some important mediators of the
killing effect so what are the micrornas
contained
in the um nk derived um
uh exosomes we have a list here uh done
in collaboration with dr seeger
chla and among the different candidates
we were really interested in the one
that has been highlighted mere 186
the reason being because it is predicted
bioinformatically to target
some very important genes in
neuroblastoma
such as mick and that as you know is
that
driving oncogene in this disease and as
you know also as of now
it is not a targetable gene because
pharmacologically
it's impossible to target mick and so
using a microrna to target it could be
an interesting um approach in addition
to that you see the tgf data receptor
one is a predicted target
as well as downstream mediators of the
tgf beta receptor pathways
so smart two and three and alk and
aurora kinase a which is also an and
stabilizer of mechan so by targeting
aurora kinase a you can
also indirectly target mechanics so for
all these reason
reasons we focused on mere 186 but first
i just want to show you this slide that
shows that with
a technique based on size exclusion
chromatography
we were able to um separate different
isolate different
fractions of extracellular vesicles and
you can observe that the marker cd81
tsg101 of exosones starts appearing in
fractions that would say between
11 and 14 which happens to be also where
you have
the highest amount of mere 186 which is
contained in the nk derived exosome and
an acceptable amount of contaminating
proteins
which come out later on in
later fractions so using this method
we decided to proceed with our
experiment but first we wanted to see if
mere 186 actually targets the geno the
genes of interest and here you can see
that if you transfect
neuroblastoma cell lines to different
lines with mere 186 you have down
regulation of mcn aurora kinase a
and we performed also um lucifer as
reporter assays
showing that indeed mere 186 targets
directly
mcn and aurora kinase a and this effect
is
exactly in the predicted binding site
because if you mutagenize these sites or
you delete it
then the luciferase activity is not
reduced anymore
but then we observed also that the mir
is targeting the tgf data signaling
um by targeting smart2 and smart three
luciferase was not uh significant for
zlatwe so that means that the mir is not
directly targeting
these two genes but indirectly we don't
know exactly what is the mediator of
this
silencing but we know also that in
addition to tgs beta r1
mr186 also targets dgf beta r2 so both
receptors
and this is quite profound because as i
told you tgf data is an immunosuppressor
because it interacts with the tgf
data pathway very important
is that the graph that you see in the
see in the bottom
left side because here we use the
reporter
system to show activation of the tgf
data pathway
and here we show that even in presence
of the agonists of tgf beta
the pathway is completely silenced
if mere 186 is expressed so
that tells you that mere 186 effect on
the pathway is so profound
that it's its presence is able to block
the activation of the pathway
even in presence of the agonist of tgs
data itself
we perform the growth curve for the
neuroblastoma cell lines in presence of
mere 186
showing that their growth is reduced and
also in a scratch
wound healing assay we observe that the
presence of mir186 reduces the migration
of neuroblastoma cells
and reduces also the migration in
presence of a chemo attract them through
a trans well
um migration assays so all of these
experiments essentially are in agreement
with a tumor suppressive role of mere
186
then we were able dr naviani was able to
generate um
anionic lipopolyplex nanoparticles
containing mere 186
and they can be actually um coated with
different type of antibodies and
according to the type of antibodies that
you
coat them with you can direct them in
their microrna content with to one cell
or another of the tumor micro
environment
here is just to show that the if you
transfect
nk cells with these nanoparticles
containing mere 186
in particular if you coat them with the
antibody against the cd56 which is the
market for mk cells you're able to
deliver more efficiently this mere in nk
cells and you can find it also in the
exosomes derived from nk cells
and likewise if you silence near 186
with an anti
um near 186 log nucleic acid
antisense we perform these uh
internal b you see the dow regulation of
the relevant genes dgf beta receptor 1
and 2 in
nk cells so we have here a situation
where the same microrna can be
beneficial both if you transfer it to
the cancer cells because of its effect
on mick and and relevant oncogenes
but also on the mk cells themselves
because by silencing tgf beta receptor
expression and the downstream pathway
you can silence the inhibitory effect of
tgf data on the nk
function and then we perform the in vivo
experiment
showing that in orthotopic models of
neuroblastoma so here we injected
neuroblastoma cells in the perirenal
capsule of these
mice where neuroblastoma develops and
these
cells are and lucifer is expressing so
you can actually
follow the growth of the tumor in the
four groups of animals in the upper side
you see the animals treated with
injection of the nanoparticles as they
showed you before
containing scramble so nothing in them
and coated with an a specific igg
antibody
and you see that the tumors keep growing
whereas
in the second group you have a
nanoparticle containing near 186 and
coated with
an a specific antibody in the third
group from the top you see the
nanoparticle containing scramble encoded
with anti-gd2 antibody gd2 is a specific
surface marker for neuroblastoma and
then the fourth group
so the bottom row of mice which is the
actual experimental group
here you have animals treated with
nanoparticles containing near 186
encoded with anti-gd2 antibody
so clearly because probably the
nanoparticle is more effective in
delivering the mirror to the cancer
cells
you see that the tumors grow much much
less and the survival is
increased so overall um i will summarize
these uh um findings by saying that
extracellular vesicles as you um
i hope you have been convinced by now
can be classified in different subtypes
and exosomes are a subtype of eds
these are involved in several aspects of
cancer biology as
the literature i briefly mentioned
showed you
evrna's shape vrna shapes the biology of
the tumor microenvironment in particular
micrornas can affect this biology by
working through the traditional
mechanisms and alternative mechanisms
including that binding to a receptor
and activation of its downstream
signaling tlr8 represents the first form
and as of now the only one i'm aware of
of mere sectors a receptor for micrornas
it is important for cancer growth
dissemination are resistant to therapy
mere 186 in nk's derived exosome
as an anti-tumor effect likely working
by targeting mcn or a kinase a and
blocking the tgf beta receptor and
downstream signaling pathway and
antibody coated nanoparticles can
specifically deliver microrna or
antimicron a cargo to target cells
and i would like to conclude by
acknowledging um
several people in my previous lab at the
children's hospital los angeles the dr
nediani is in the upper picture the
second one from the left
who performed several experiments i
showed you
and um people in my uh
more recently established a lab at the
university of hawaii cancer
center in the bottom picture and of
course the funding agencies that
supported these
studies at the um both federal agencies
and private foundation and of course the
patients and their families were
providing the samples for these studies
and i thank you so much for your
attention i will
wait for your questions that you might
have and i will
try to answer them as soon as possible
thank you so much